hello and welcome to this video play I
am you wise QG something from me
come on I need to get rid of this window
that's irritating you guys GG okay - no
I've played it before I did yeah
actually two times and one win one loss
okay get this this is a interesting line
luck basically tries to play again
normal Wow did a blunder something it's
a bit unusual to take now just give up
the bishop pair what is that phone I am
right
[Music]
three uncommon enter to teat to take
this 93 I'm actually feel tempted to
play b5 him to make the night look
strange 95 and c5 he might take and play
Queen to g6 or something like that I
don't know if this is a good idea but
yeah but I still want to do this just to
be be ready to be active Queen that
20:36 doesn't do much so go back here
rook t1 Bishop e6 is very okay for black
I think at least in to see 7:01 p.m.
okay so what do I do I want to do here
in this position
Bishop to f8 for c4 probably he will
reroute this anyway yeah I think this is
this is on no matter what
hmm play a bishop to evade anyway kind
of that's what stream share we seem to
think along completely different lines
here
this was my ladies room my next move
anyway so kind of weird that he put it
on c5 and also it fold is standard yeah
blacks idea here totally standard so I
wonder that he gave it gave it to me
that that easily
[Music]
[Music]
try to activate this yg5 maybe it's not
really working yeah got it got it there
hmm yeah my Lucas actor but it's not
really doing all that much maybe I have
to have to trade queens and then look a
three at the enter to attack a c3 pawn
yeah okay three I mean I totally control
the default it cannot enter them and how
does he cover it
[Music]
so it's a straightforward way of working
1978 b6f for take it
probably not as the king will will come
their keyword she will help out
[Music]
[Music]
I put it on CA to d6o this is what I
want to do check
[Music]
- siento on the H file or something time
warning
so can I do my share
the way he's playing it you might lose
it I should have played f3 actually no
maybe I'm still in time
[Music]
ah come on come on this is still good
try to believe I played right I don't
know II was a bit crazy maybe headed 12
seconds this position it was so
extremely awful for white that maybe
this still works
I have 12 seconds though the f-pawn I
mean he plays without this Bishop there
[Music]
you've wriggled himself out of it
at least I'm timewise
check okay he went sometime I would have
shame what for fence on time it was so
it was so busted some some really
strange maneuvers there yeah I mean
black is always better but it's
difficult to win here probably this is
objectively a draw I mean there was some
some some ideas here back and forth I
still wanted to try to win and also have
only have 30 seconds so I had to try
things and this was funky idea it's it
I don't know I mean his pieces are so
awkward that this is probably working at
least the engine crews I mean this is
this even is an interesting move but it
just felt so far fall short just
narrowly trap so here I'm probably
winning somehow came to f6 look a 6
through k5 my computer gives it a draw
Jim okay he did was a crapshoot again
with with the time yeah it doesn't
really matter that objectively black
black Vince there then the quiet also he
knew that he was winning on time so
there was no need for him to do anything
the thing that interests me actually is
do I have
wind somewhere here because here by
what's position is in total disarray I
really wonder if there was something to
punish what he did
yeah Knight to a4 but he's getting he's
probably getting to the to in time the
engine wants to put it on f4 annoyed
yeah it's a super one-sided position but
not sure of you you can win actually
with hindsight I wonder yeah I am Bishop
g5 f5 and to widest completely busted
him yeah yeah with that with the double
ports the pawn structure became too
rigid game yeah this is pretty awful
this is pretty awful g3 by the computer
yeah the thing is I mean I'm probably
just advancing here like f4 Bishop f6 it
wants to play first I don't know if this
is essential yeah
this is somebody's a lot stronger yeah I
can I have all kinds of ideas now Bishop
comes over here and so on this is a lot
better
we should Bishop g5 looks kind of kind
of logical as like the bishop doesn't
look very active and and yeah that's
that's a strategic mistake I mean it
gives up a huge chunk of the advantage
very interesting am never give up your
bishop pair yeah it's more about the
pawn structure but it's also about the
bishop pair the bishop is getting strong
here and I don't want to trade the
consoles from less space
yeah Bishop g5 is a strategic mistake a
very substantial one yeah in comparison
to what black hairs here interesting
okay that was an instructive movement
there ready yeah okay thanks for
watching